first of all human reasoning did not evolve
as a way of figuring out the world it evolved
as a means for us providing plausible sounding
justifications for what it is that we want to
get in a social situation so we you know we
reason in order to come up with good excuses
for why what we want is what everybody should
want to it is a a source of cognitive bias it
means that we we [__] but we are not capable
ourselves of detecting or smelling our own [__]
okay so that's part one of the AR the second
part of the argument is where it gets really
interesting that we are terrible at detecting
our own [__] but because this is so important
you know so because we are a social uh species we
are by and large we're pretty good at detecting
others [__] and so then this means that uh
you can harness people's cognitive bias against
each other so you and I disagree strenuously on
sort of I don't know who who who has to pay for
dinner I've got great arguments on my side you've
got great arguments on your side uh but are but
probably at the beginning we don't have great
arguments I've got terrible arguments and you
round immediately on the flaw in my argument
and I round on the flaw in your argument but
at the very least we end up with better arguments
so the fundamental notion here is that individual
level cognitive flaws can result in better group
level reasoning if we are prepared to engage with
other people who we disagree with what this is
it suggests that you can use people's Tendencies
to be [__] as the fuel for actual good not
collaboration but for actually obser figuring
stuff out there is a work that has been done
by a Chicago sociologist James Evans he uses
uh he and his colleagues use national natural
language processing to look at Wikipedia and to
look at the the amount of disagreement there
is on Wikipedia pages and the uh fundamental
finding that they find is that the greater the
degree of polarization and attention that there
is in a given Wikipedia talk page the better
the quality of the resulting argument so this
is not because people end up loving each other
and singing Kumbaya they still hate each other
at the end of the day uh but they grudgingly
recognize that there are good arguments it's
kind of like that uh onion article the worst
person I know just made a great argument this
is the logic that we can actually harness to
make Democratic institutions work better and
Wikipedia because it is able to harness the
someone on the Internet is wrong thing and
make that into a force of intellectual Discovery
is a very very interesting model for us to do it